knows what do you think when you hear
that sentence man it sounds damn good
damn good been a lot of work man a lot
of work
going to a new team everybody staying
the course that team fight hard
t-loo unbelievable coach chauncey
billers
my big brother so many ties to that team
but damn this feels good
chris in this game there was a point the
clippers cut it to seven
you then scored 14 of 16 points on your
way
to 41 for the game what kind of mission
were you on
don't lose don't lose mission
you know what i'm saying i am not feel
good i wish my son and my family come
down here
i don't know man it's just a lot of
emotions a lot of injuries i was getting
an mri yesterday on my wrist
a lot of [ __ ] going on excuse me i'm
sorry i just want to get over there with
my team rage
respect appreciate you i'll talk to you
when i give you the trophy how about
that
back to you mike you could just
you could hear the emotion in his voice
again
it's taken him 16 years one of the
premier point guards throughout his
entire
nba career now at age 36
remember a few years ago people are
starting to say he was on his decline
what he did last year was magnificent
with okc just getting them
into the playoffs and then this year
comes to a phoenix suns team that had
not been to the playoffs since 2010
and here they are in the nba finals
every single one of these young players
talk about the impact
that he's had so now they'll await the
winner
of the east and that's going to resume
tomorrow night on tnt
game five tip off shortly after 8 30
eastern hawks and bucks
not sure if trey young's going to play
we know giannis atherakuppo will not
play
although his injury not as serious
yeah you you my friend
[Applause]
it's been a long time 16 years
tens of thousands of hours in the gym
when no one is watching chris
i saw the tears before what does this
mean to you to take in this moment when
you think back
on all those times man uh
i'm just so happy for all the people
around me you know what i mean
and they're doing here in l.a with the
clippers this is my family too
i gave six hard years to the clippers we
fought hard
a lot of these fans billy crystal that's
my family
you know what i mean you know what i
mean so to do it here
against the team that i got the utmost
respect for i'll always be a clipper i
love these fans
you know what i mean but this crew right
here
this crew right here this game right
here
man since day one they opened me
they welcomed me with open arms coach we
did this 10 years ago in new orleans
and we still got a lot of work to do but
we're going to enjoy this and my family
up top i love y'all y'all see him right
there
that's my game straight up 16 years of
this
16 years surgeries hard work
losses bad losses but we're gonna enjoy
tonight we're gonna enjoy it
you've talked in this playoffs how a lot
of people thought when you went to
oklahoma city okay well he's just gonna
finish his career out that way without
another bite at the apple
of tasting something like this yeah
rachel i'm gonna tell you i write
something on my shoes every game is
called
to say can't give up now mary mary got a
song
called can't give up now i listened to
it the day i got traded to okc
that's why i write it on my shoes every
game straight up